I can't crack Instagram it's hard the
views are so down because the supply and
demand is an issue there's so much
content being put out on Instagram and a
lot of the youth attention went to tick
tock so the opportunity I think sits in
Facebook more than Instagram today and
Facebook reels but there is still tons
of opportunity on Instagram have you
done any green screens that it's the
creative strategy remember this term
sock strategic organic content you're
just making organic content and you're
doing what comes natural even I get into
those patterns and I do this for a
living right so it's about mixing it up
you know what I'm talking about with the
green screen pound that